The development was to lead to man, woman, spermatozoa set out for an onslaught.
They passed through a fantastic obstacle course.
Only 1% of them will succeed in breaking through the barrier created by the neck of the womb.
Survivors will die of exhaustion in the cavity of the womb.
They'll be captured in the traps of the fallopian tube.
Very few of them will succeed in getting anywhere near the egg cell.
Committed to the hundreds of millions set out and the secret entrance disappear.
You always are such idiots.
They look right now.
Everything can start happening.
First day of fertilization.
The second day.
Fourth days.
The divisions of the fertilized egg have become too numerous to come.
The neck of the womb closes up again to preserve the fertilized egg,
which within a few days will attach itself to the wall of the womb.
The 28th day.
It is already an embryo.
Embryo surrounded by an outer membrane like an envelope,
part of which forms the placenta.
Placenta helps to feed the growing embryo.
Here, I'm listening.
Supplementary cells for the skeleton, the skin and the heart, what?
You're a nuisance, I can't do everything.
Everybody has his speciality, you should know that.
Hello, Chromosome Center.
We have an order for you from the cells.
Put Operation Mitosis into effect at once.
Down there, get to work.
Chromosomes, get up!
Just like the others, isn't he?
You think so?
Why don't you have a closer look?
There, come now.
Ming.
I don't want this one.
Slot, I'll do them.
What do you think you're trying to do?
Cause a genetic accident?
Jolly...
Bone cells, platform number 17.
Platform number 22.
Cells, conduct yourselves in an orderly fashion.
There are 200 different kinds of you,
so without discipline,
we'll never get where we're going.
Hurry along there to your platform, please.
Cells for the liver, platform 8.
Cells for the muscles, platform 10.
In cells, platform number 14.
Calm, please. Move along.
Don't push, please. There's room for everyone.
No.
Cells for the heart, platform 19.
Let's have some order, please.
Bone cells, platform 17.
Liver cells, platform number 8.
Cells for the muscles, platform 10.
Cells for the skin.
35th day, the embryo or fetus is 6 millimeters long.
By the 42nd day, it is 12 millimeters.
By the 50th day, 20 millimeters.
And team, your platform comes up next.
Platform number 17 will be done there, and you, chief?
Way out west to the humerus, there's new land there to conquer.
You can't treat us like this. You're so right.
I agree, they can't.
Then, everyone, good news.
Further west towards the forearm, there are immense territories to conquer.
It's a brand new land. Follow us. Yippee! Come.
You'll need it urgent. Seed at once to platform 4.
Washing? It is true. It's impossible, unless you fly.
An eye cell, silly fool, not a fly cell.
My cells, we're sending a detachment of engineers to open the way for you.
Throw us.
For the retina, to the right.
I'll trip.
Cells for the crystalline lens, follow me.
35 millimetres.
Send me a messenger.
Cell commander, troops are exhausted and need nourishment.
Right off you go.
Collagen, ovalbumin, yes, I've got that.
Pick this order.
Collagen and ovalbumin right away.
722, needed at the duplicating room.
It's an emergency.
Neither do you. I don't understand this machine.
Well, it'll just have to do.
That's fine, the RNA messenger's been sent off.
It's okay, that'll do. That's good.
Oh, no, no, not that. No, no, I need a U.
Got it wrong.
It's all you two, you're in the race.
Yes, that's all right, next.
Teens ready.
20 days, 20 centimetres.
40 days, 25 centimetres.
170 days, 30 centimetres.
200 days, 35 centimetres.
25 days, 40 centimetres.
150 days, 45 centimetres.
170 days, 9 months, 50 centimeters.
3.2 kilograms.
Assembly of spillion cells. A single fertilized cell has manufactured
muscles and skin, skeleton and brain, heart and lungs,
nails, arms and legs. Generation after generation, a single cell has made